what's going on guys today we're going
to be theorizing what it would be like
if there was an additional shift in
attack on titan that was specifically
made to be underwater a titan of that
nature would have completely changed
naval warfare given that it would be
like a one-person mini submarine that
could also just start throwing punches
in this video i'll be breaking down all
the abilities that i think a sea titan
would need to have but there are a
couple important things worth mentioning
first number one is that pretty much any
titan can survive in the water because
breathing is not required for them to
live essentially meaning there is no
chance of a titan ever dying from
drowning and i assume the same rule
presumably applies to titan shifters as
well in the end credits for season 3 we
saw pure titans casually emerging from
the ocean like it was nothing and in the
mangrove confirmed beyond any doubt that
they can swim without needing to come up
for air that being said though even
though titans can survive in the water
none of them have features that are
specifically made for that environment
hence why migas said that they can't
intervene when it comes to naval
conflicts the second thing i wanted to
point out before we get into it was that
although an underwater shifter doesn't
exist it's entirely possible that a
previous beast titan was based off a sea
creature whether it be a whale a shark
or even a giant titan squid in my
opinion the opening for season two
definitely implied that might have been
the case and also a t-rex as well but
without further ado let's move over to
what powers the sea titan should have
and don't forget to smash that sub
button if you haven't already
okay so starting with this design most
of the body would be covered in blue
scales made from a new type of titan
hardening giving the shifter a degree of
camouflage in the water and also
allowing it to glide faster the scales
help to reduce water resistance so when
you combine that feature with its insane
physical strength webbed hands and the
right swimming technique it can propel
itself faster through the ocean than any
actual sea creature at its top speed it
can swim from the shore of parodies to
the mali and continent in just under 5
hours although it might take longer in
reality depending on the experience of
the user at the front of its mouth is a
special organ that was initially
inspired by humpback whales as those
creatures can emit a low frequency sound
wave to communicate with other wheels
over ridiculously long distances for the
underwater titan this organ can emit a
continuous pulse that is sent through
pars which can only be felt by the
holders of the other titan shifters once
the pulse is received they all become
aware of the underwater titan's location
with the signal getting more powerful
the closer they get the pulse works
regardless of whether the shifter is on
land or sea and it can be used as an sos
signal that would lead allies towards
its location the downside is that enemy
titan shifters would also know where the
underwater titan is hiding however with
the right tactics that could be a good
thing for lonely opposition into a trap
in order to fully explain what i mean by
that let's imagine a scenario in which
parodies are the ones who had this
shifter as it would have made their
strategy a lot more effective during the
declaration of war instead of sending in
yelena to try and trap the warriors the
sea titan could have camped underneath
the malian port and released a pulse
that all the warriors would have felt
that pulse would be felt incredibly
strongly by them considering the port
isn't that far away from where they were
and i reckon porker would immediately
storm off in that direction pique would
probably be following behind him to make
sure he doesn't get himself killed while
zeke would volunteer to remain near the
stage since he'd be planning to hit
travis on the airship pretty soon lara
tyber would have felt the pulse as well
and would likely tell her brother
straight away but as the final season
made clear willie knew he was going to
be attacked and was fully prepared to
die so in my mind i have no doubt that
he's still go ahead with his declaration
anyway remember that the first main step
in the attack on liberio was to prevent
as many ships as possible from getting
in eren's way so at the port the
underwater titan would continue to
generate that pulse until at least one
of the marlin warriors arrive
i think pique would be skeptical of
parodies decision to make their presence
known like this although for the sake of
this example we'd have to imagine that
they would still go towards it once
those two show up at the port then of
course the pulse would be revealed to be
a diversion as the sea titan could
propel itself far away at top speed
while the colossal tags in and blows the
place up by swimming away the sea titan
can quickly escape the blast radius but
those who wouldn't be able to escape
include thousands of civilians any
nearby ships and most importantly two
titan shifters that now can't intervene
in the main battle and also can't
intervene in any future battle as well
in this example you can see how the
pulse being sent to all shifters can be
a big benefit for luring enemies into
traps and in that aspect the colossal
and sea titans would make a nice tag
team
moving on when it comes to the amount of
transformations the shifter can do in a
single day there are a few factors
involved including the energy required
to make it the natural endurance of that
titan and sometimes the extent of the
user's injuries for the sea titan
however i imagine there would be a
different factor that has the biggest
impact and that is whether or not the
user is on dry land or in the water when
they're attempting to transform i kind
of felt like there needed to be one more
thing that would make sure the shifter
stays in the water most of the time
given that in theory someone could just
decide to use this mainly on land even
though it wasn't necessarily designed
for that bearing that in mind if the
user of the underwater titan is on the
surface then they can only transform one
time and they won't be able to do it
again until their human body is
completely submerged in water it doesn't
necessarily have to be water from the
ocean i mean i guess it could be a lake
or a public pool but as long as the
specific criteria is met and the human
body is in the water completely then it
should be able to do a maximum of five
consecutive transformations on a given
day
additionally as you would expect from a
shifter with this name its eyes would
have adapted so it seems better
underwater compared to the other titans
in all honesty i have no idea how
clearly most titans can see when they're
submerged in water but all i know is
that for me personally without goggles
it looks like i'm seeing things in 240p
resolution a shifter made for the water
definitely shouldn't have that type of
problem although if it starts going
hundreds and hundreds of meters deep
then yeah it might need to get a
flashlight with that all explained i
guess the final feature to mention is
that its height would be 70 meters tall
putting it in the same class as the
beast titan and it would have enough
stamina for around 6 to 10 hours of
intense swimming a day
if marley had this thing then it's
guaranteed they'd use it for naval
warfare as commander mcgather revealed
the malian navy was lacking compared to
other countries with a titan like this
they'd likely use it to destroy enemy
fleets by charging into the battleships
one by one but inevitably the other
nations would develop technology to
specifically counter this threat
as a random side note if this was an
actual titan then i'm fairly certain
there would be a brutal swimming
schedule added to the malian warrior
candidate program on the flip side
parodies could have really done with the
shifts themselves as it's pretty much
the perfect titan to have if you're
going to send a spy to learn more about
mali if we had to pick someone to
inherit it who is not already a titan
shifter then i say it would probably go
to jean or maybe hanji but the trouble
with her is that yes she would gather
the most information but she's also the
most likely to blow her cover without
levi there to keep her in check
anyhow in summarizing the abilities of
the sea titan it has a couple physical
features to help it glide faster through
the water and at its top speed it should
be the fastest sea creature on the
planet
obviously the speed varies depending on
the experience of the user and how well
they've been trained but as a general
rule it should take no longer than 7
total hours to swim from mali to
paradise importantly it also has the
power to send a continuous pulse through
parts that will always alert other
shifters to its location the strength of
the pulse will give each individual
shifter a good idea of how close or far
away they might be and although the
pulse is continuous it can be turned on
and off at any given time thirdly the
sea titan has good eyesight in the water
and can transform a maximum of once a
day on the surface but five times
overall let me know down below in the
comments what do you think of this titan
and also who in parodies would be chosen
to inherit it if the islands somehow
managed to take it for themselves
thanks for watching as always and if you
haven't seen it already then don't
forget to check out my video on the past
titan as that was the other shifter i
thought would be a cool addition to the
series until the next one peace out